a minute's silence to honor thousands of
Chinese who lost their lives to the
coronavirus said a somber tone for the
opening of China's National People's
Congress delivering the annual
government work report Premier Li
Keqiang
hailed the Communist Party's achievement
in containing the outbreak and also
acknowledged the heavy economic cost for
the first time since 1988 no GDP growth
target was set we did our success has
come at a great price the economy posted
negative growth in the first quarter of
this year and a daily life and the work
have been greatly affected no mention
either of any large-scale economic
stimulus for the world's second-largest
economy instead communist officials were
told to tighten their belts and focus on
stabilizing employment and eradicating
poverty the government plans to create 9
million jobs and cap unemployment at the
current rate of 6 percent but analysts
say millions of daily wage workers are
not included in the official tally the
number one priority is the employment
issue so to create jobs and employment -
this word is mentioned almost 40 times
and the government is talking about
different programs on different levels
of government defense spending is due to
rise by 6.6 percent its slowest rate in
three decades but enforcing national
security in Hong Kong is being stepped
up with the announcement of a proposed
law banning treason secession and
subversion there activists say the draft
law is an assault on the region's
autonomy and democratic freedoms Xi
Jinping had torn away the whole pretense
of one country to a system so they are
announcing to the world that Hong Kong
is no longer under one country to system
it is now one country one system Hong
Kong's main Hang Seng Index fell by more
than five percent with investors fearing
the loss of the financial centers
special economic status president Don
Trump says the US will
respond strongly to the proposed
legislation the National People's
Congress will continue to meet over the
next week but on Friday its priorities
were made clear reviving the economy and
closing in on any threat to China
stability via the corona virus or
demands for democracy Katrina you
al-jazeera
Beijing